-I'm so happy
that you're here in studio.
-I believe you.
-Yeah. [ Laughs ]
Last time you were on, I got you
to Zoom, which was unbelievable.
That'll never happen again
in the history of my lifetime,
will I get you on Zoom.
-No. No.
That's correct.
-And I loved that.
I love that that happened
for me, just as a --
It's the little wins
that make me happy.
But we talked about
"Pretend It's a City,"
which is a great miniseries
on Netflix.
If you just -- If you just
want to laugh, just put this on.
You are so observant and have
a different view of everything
wherever you go, from crossing
the street to anything.
Is there anything happening now
in New York City
that you're going, like,
"Okay, I'm noticing this"?
-I did notice that the very
first thing that came back,
months ago, was traffic.
[ Laughter ]
Okay? So, there's like --
No one is here.
There's nowhere to go.
Everything's closed.
No one's working.
No one's going to school.
Nothing is open.
There's no place to go,
but there was just traffic.
[ Laughter ]
-No place -- That is true.
-I thought this is kind of,
you know,
traffic in its purest form,
you know, traffic
with no purpose at all.
It's just, you know, traffic
that was probably sent here
by a hostile foreign power.
[ Laughter ]
Just traffic sitting there,
and of course, everyone
was driving very recklessly,
honking the horns.
I think, "Where you going?
What's the big rush?
There's nowhere to go."
-There's actually nowhere to go.
That's the first thing
to come back.
-Right. So traffic was
first thing to come back.
-What do you think about
legalization of marijuana?
-You know, I haven't taken drugs
since I was 19,
but I don't care
what other people do at all.
But it does seem to me
since it was legalized
for recreational use --
I love that term,
"recreational use" --
It seems that it wasn't
just legalized, it seems --
made legal -- it seems like
it was made mandatory.
You know.
[ Laughter ]
The streets of New York
are clouds of weed.
You can't -- If you don't
want to smoke marijuana,
you have no choice,
you know, basically.
-It is unbelievable.
-Every single person.
-Everyone is, yeah.
-Except me.
-Yeah. Yeah, me, too.
You walk by a construction site,
and it is the --
-And that's really shocking,
because there they are.
They're hanging
from these beams,
and I think, you know,
it's not me
that's going to fall, you know?
-Yeah, exactly.
How high do you want to be?
Yeah, there you go.
Thank you. Thank you very much.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now, I want to give this a plug
even though you're not here
to plug anything,
which, you're just here
because you're a good friend.
But this is
"The Fran Lebowitz Reader,"
and I encourage anyone
to get this, if you get this,
because it is exactly this
funny, and it's a great read,
and I just never get a chance
to plug anything for you.
But I know you're back
doing shows.
You're doing -- You do shows
where someone interviews you
for 30 minutes,
and then you answer questions
with the audience.
-Right, someone interviews me
on a stage...
-Yeah.
-...for 30 minutes.
And then they leave.
-Mm.
-Just mentioning. Just saying.
[ Laughter ]
And then I go to a lectern,
and I answer questions
from the audience for an hour.
-That's, so, April 6th and 7th,
you're at a town hall
here in New York.
So everyone has to go to this,
'cause this will be
unbelievable.
You get to see Fran Lebowitz
in person.
For information, which is --
This is great, again --
there is not yet a website
currently, 'cause this is Fran.
So, you're on your Facebook.
Facebook.com/FranLebowitz.
We're going to put it
on the thing.
How did you end up
even setting that up?
-I didn't.
[ Laughter ]
I didn't -- I've never seen it.
My agent did it. It's like --
By the way,
I've never seen Netflix.
-Yeah.
-I've never seen it.
And when I --
this was coming out,
I would ask people,
"Do you have Netflix?"
And they would look at me
like I was asking,
"Do you have electricity?"
Because apparently there's
one person in the country
that doesn't have Netflix.
That's me.
-Yeah. We love you.
Come back whenever and Zoom me
whenever you want to.
-I won't, don't worry.
-Fran Lebowitz, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, I want to show --
Let me show a clip.
I want to show a clip
of the show.
Here's a clip of Fran
in "Pretend It's a City."
Take a look at this.
-I don't know if they do to you
where you have your own,
actually, young child.
I didn't mean a little child,
but a teenager.
-Yes. Yes.
-But people that age,
the age of your daughter --
-Yes.
-...and somewhat older,
very often approach me
to ask me my opinion
of what they should do in life.
Like, you know, "Fran --"
And I just think, like,
first of all,
I don't care what you do.
[ Laughter ]
They're so used to being, like,
the center
of their parents' attention,
that anyone they see that age,
they just think, like,
you know, "Maybe this person
will help me out."
But that would be a mistake
with me, because --
[ Laughter ]
-That is so exactly
on the money.
Fran Lebowitz, everybody!
Check out this book, by the way,
"The Fran Lebowitz Reader."
"Pretend It's a City"
is on Netflix now.
Go to Fran's Facebook page
for more info
to see her live in town hall!
She's all over.